this episode of the minimalist is
brought to you by nobody
because advertisements suck this podcast
has bad words
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua phillips milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists today we're going to
talk about our obsessions
our obsessions with trends and fashion
and we're going to
dissect our infatuation with clothing
and style and also shoes and we're gonna
do that with today's guest
now it's tyler jones although tyler
isn't your name
tyler it's not no and it's a terrible
fake name as well
but yeah that's me for now so i want to
dive into this so so you started this
instagram account called preachers and
sneakers
yes and if you're watching this on
youtube right now you'll notice that you
can't see tyler's face because he is
this anonymous person
behind preachers and sneakers
let's talk would you say they called you
the christian banksy yeah several have
yeah which i which i wear with pride
yeah absolutely a better compliment
absolutely
so this account fascinates me now ryan
and i have different religious beliefs
we have different political beliefs and
i think that's what makes this
this podcast uh resonate with a lot of
people because we have
atheists on we have christians we have
everyone in between
and it's quite often not even about
beliefs and today we're not even really
going to be talking about
religious beliefs although i think that
we'll that will come into the
conversation our beliefs in general will
come into the conversation
what i want to talk about is this
obsession we have with fashion and i
think
no one has done that in a more artistic
way that has spurred conversation
recently than you thank you
let's talk about what happened how did
preachers and sneakers start for those
who were
who are not in the know yet so uh as
most young married men do when their
wives are out of town
i was sitting on my couch watching
worship videos on
youtube so like you guys have differing
religious beliefs i'm a
i'm a christian been for the majority of
my life and
i never do this but for whatever reason
that morning i was
i slept through church and was just
watching worship videos on youtube i
there was a song that i liked called
resurrecting by elevation worship which
is
you know one of the larger worship bands
right now
um and i was watching the video and i
noticed the lead singer who's not the
least singer anymore but
uh his name is mac brock was wearing
this pair of yeezy 750s
and at that time i had been into
sneakers for maybe three or four years
and i very quickly realized oh these
shoes resell
for eight hundred dollars and uh for
whatever
there was a i think i had you was either
under over caffeinated and i just
started to feel
some type of irritation like how how do
you reconcile this
uh and i wasn't this articulate at the
time but i'm not articulate now but i
i just was very frustrated and i
couldn't understand wait this dude's
leaning worship
for thousands of people and he's wearing
shoes that are worth more than most of
their rent
i would assume yeah right like what kind
of message is that sending right
and um and at the same time i was like i
i can guarantee that most people don't
understand how much these shoes are
worth
and then you know youtube serves up
recommend recommended videos
for after those videos and i started
realizing there's a ton
of pastors and worship leaders that are
wearing all these super
hyped up sneakers and street wear and so
i just made a few videos
on my personal instagram and she said
hey did you know that
uh you know mac brock is wearing 800
yeezys or
y'all's friend irwin is wearing 900
off-white jordan ones
um to my personal instagram i have like
400 followers i'm a nobody i know
nothing like i'm just a regular dude
and i had a buddy that actually lives
out here who's a dj he's like hey dude
you should
start an account just doing that it
could be the next
viral thing and i said i don't i don't
think so but
i mean i i love making people laugh and
like the like
how people were responding to the things
i did on my personal instagram and so i
thought about it for a few days
and the name i just started thinking
like what rhymes with
like preachers or pastors or deacons and
immediately
sneakers i said preachers and sneakers
and there's a double entendre there
right obviously and it's like in
like in as well as and
sneakers um and so i made the account
and i copied sorry
i copied those posts over and within
four weeks i had a hundred thousand
followers
it's crazy the new york times is calling
and i'm like dude i don't know what i
just did let's talk a bit about this so
what you found also is and this is one
of those rare examples where social
media
actually leads to healthy conversation
in a lot of instances
the the comment section has in many ways
become
this artistic space in and of itself
right yeah
and it's uh there's plenty of people
that are more funny
and more educated than i am in the
comments section and that was the thing
that was so surprising
that we're talking about earlier like
fans of your podcasts are atheists and
religious
and questioning and all this and
all those same types of people were
coming in the comments section because
the universal thing is everyone felt a
certain type of way
about it and a lot of people didn't know
what to do with it
because they were served up oh this
person is wearing 1200
shoes i don't know how to feel about
that right yeah and that's what i think
caused um so many people to get
riled up one way or the other well you
know it's interesting when i first saw
preachers and sneakers
i had this visceral reaction like you
did yeah you saw the easies
but then i started digging into it and
i'm like so torn on it now
yeah cause it's uh yeah i could see both
sides of it and maybe we'll get more
into that
in the maximal episode but yeah i think
so and also uh tyler so so
you and in fact i made sure not to ask
your name beforehand so i wouldn't screw
it up
because i don't want to do the big
reveal uh and and so
you you had this quote i think it was in
a complex article you said as i have
processed the growth of this account
however
it has caused me to examine my own life
and how i spend my money because
it's not much different so in a way
while you were reflecting and you were
judging other people in a way at first
i think now what you do isn't a judgment
so much as it is a
you're setting up a discussion board
almost uh a community discussion board
but it's made you look inward as well
and start to examine your own life yeah
i i would i still hold too that i wasn't
judging anyone i was at least
trying to understand why i felt a
certain type of way about it like why
naturally i was averse to the idea that
pastors and worship leaders could either
be gifted such nice things or
make enough money to where they could
just straight up be buying these type of
things right
um i it's still up for discussion kind
of like ryan
i've i've seen behind the curtain on
some of these things and i've
i understand the nuance around some of
the situations like at a micro level
there are variables that all of us
don't get privy like aren't privy to and
change the narrative a little bit
yeah um what was your original question
sorry
no it's it's changed your own mind oh
yeah in a way so so
are you looking at the shoes you buy now
a little bit differently yeah i mean it
made me
really really take inventory of my own
social media presence and question why i
was posting what i post
because at least in christian circles a
lot of what we post
on social media is really if if you get
deep down into it is to make other
people
jealous at some level of our lives oh
wow and so that
and i had to repent of that myself
saying like oh i had these courtside
seats and i posted all about it because
i wanted people to know
that i got this sweet hookup or that i
was on the sweet vacation or had this
dope meal
and at least in christian circles i mean
causing people to envy your life
is sin and so i had to really like go
back and say oh
why like it's really caused me to
reflect on why i post on social media
and really try to take the log out of my
own eye yeah even though it's been
imperfect and it's been messy and you
guys have seen the comments like
critics of mine will say this is not a
healthy discussion
but it is a discussion and it's caused
people to do the same
well i mean i think we should have a
little bit of that discussion we have
some some listener
questions we're going to get to here in
a moment but i thought what was
fascinating is
ryan saw that had that visceral reaction
at first i actually had a different
visceral reaction and i think
you and and we the minimalists in our
community
we are actually talking about the same
problem which i think is over
indulgent consumerism but we're tackling
it from from different angles
and i actually don't have much of a
problem with pastors
i mean i shouldn't say much i don't have
any problem with a pastor wearing
expensive shoes because i think they
they they work a job and they can do
whatever they want with that money the
same way i don't care whether or not you
wear
expensive shoes however i actually have
more of a problem
with with just your average person like
me and ryan
who aren't you know fashion critics or
whatever uh spending money actually
we're not even average because we now we
have this audience or whatever but like
yeah podcast sean for example
if he started wearing um 800
yeezys um i would start to question his
priorities
yeah in a way and now that maybe that's
me
you know judgment is but a mirror right
right and it reflects the insecurities
of the person who's doing the judging so
if i were to look at sean and say
hey those i'm not going to say it out
loud but i'm going to look at that and
say
wow he really prioritizes
uh this expensive footwear and why is he
doing that is it a personal belief is it
a memetic belief we'll get into some of
that today
as well but when i look at someone like
him
just spending 800 on on sneakers that
would seem
frivolous to me but when i see someone
who is influential i'm really i'm really
fascinated by people who influence other
people now
that could be someone like erwin mcmanus
like you mentioned his church is right
across the street from here i watched
all this conversation uh
great looking guy and by the way he we
just did another thing with him for
netflix
and he uh he talks about some things in
a way
that will i think we could talk about
some today
but he shows up he's the most dapper
person in the room and he's not dressed
differently from me he was i swear to
you he was wearing a black shirt
and black pants and somehow he he's got
swag
he was yeah he was dressed so much
better than me i'm like we're wearing
the same
outfit yeah what is going on and now the
the shoes that that um i think you you
posted him wearing some expensive shoes
and um they were gifted to him he said
um which i mean i i don't have any
reason not to believe that
right um and when i when i see
see that i also see that he's trying to
resonate with a particular community
right
and so by wearing something
you know it used to be we wore our
sunday's best right to
if we go to church i grew up catholic
right and
we were the original prosperity gospel
right um
and and we'll talk more about that as
well but but the
the church i go to you know people
wearing suits and ties and now
now it's street wear right yeah let's
let's talk about that because now it is
isn't it in many ways the same but just
a more progressive version of that
yeah it might be although so people
bring up the suits all the time
and the difference in the suits to me is
that there were rarely
brand names associated with those suits
and so it was a little harder to tell if
this dude was wearing a 300
suit or ten thousand dollar armani
that's a great point the politician john
edwards he was yeah
he so so he would be a common man he
would take his armani suits take the tag
out and have them sew in a jc penney's
tag oh wow which so he he was being
deceptive
he could have just removed the armani
tag and no one would have known
right right but he wanted to show you
that he was the the average man by
putting
so isn't that interesting how brands
communicate something
yes and so that's the deeper discussion
about okay if you're saying
that you represent the creator of the
universe or you're
or you're pouring into a congregation of
people
and not trying to have wisdom with what
you wear
are you being foolish because i think
most people would agree that what you
wear sends a message
especially if you're wearing a brand
name yeah and to go back to what kind of
what you said about podcast sean if he
was
showed up in 800 shoes i agree like i
don't have
an issue with him having those shoes but
i would i would have an
issue if he was living off of
tithes and donations and so that's
that's the rub for a lot of people
is it's hard to reconcile those two
things where
uh or that's why it blew up so
significantly i think is because
people have this understanding like all
right pastors live off tides and
offerings yet they're
wearing thousand dollar shoes but many
of the ones you feature aren't living
off tides and
offerings and then it brings up a
follow-up question like all right so
they're not living off ties and
offerings
but they're building a congregation
writing books on pastor time
and then selling it to that existing
platform that they've built
as a pastor and so it just brings up all
these deep things that i
as a normal nothing dude kind of
maybe scratch the surface of with the
sneakers and that's why people get so
fired up because there's all these
different
elements too you know what got me fired
up is uh one of the articles i was
reading i don't know if those were the
times or if it was vice but
uh it was talking about how these
churches will start to make their own
swag
and they create this false demand and i
think that
is uh that's promoting materialism
and that is where i have a problem with
any
any organization that's leading people
to promote materialism but
that's me if if i am if i'm at a if i'm
at a church
and a pastor is wearing an 800 pair of
shoes like i get to decide
whether or not i support that pastor
personally i wouldn't
but someone else would and i'm not going
to knock someone for
choosing to support a pastor who's
wearing 800 shoes but what if that
pastor
did their 800 shoes because that's the
resale value
right yeah unless it's like designer
stuff generally i post like the retail
value of designer stuff because it's
ridiculous
right yeah as on the retail side sure
sure so so
but but what if they didn't pay anything
for those sneakers
now we have people who offer us free
stuff all the time we always decline it
just just as a rule but i'm not saying
that my address
no well so the the if they're given to
them
it still is promoting materialism it is
it's just a step away
and this is what's so funny about this
whole conversation there's this line
it's such a gray area because it's to me
it's only one step away from like
wearing a nike swoosh
when they're when they're when they're
preaching and when they're on the stage
uh now it's not as obvious as a nike
swoosh like most people wouldn't have
noticed
what you noticed in that video with the
800 pair of shoes yeah um but people
will definitely notice a nike swoosh so
it's a little bit more
indiscreet but still it's it's promoting
materialism and it's not about like
you know what could they have done with
that 800 maybe they could have like
redone the upholstery on the
you know on the church benches or like
that's not really the problem i have as
much as
creating the need with the congregation
of oh my pastor wears those shoes so
like now i need to go wear those shoes
and that is uh that's where i have an
issue not only that but
it would be like if we started wearing
rolexes like yeah like
because the whole conversation about
drawing in a younger crowd like i get
that
um but that would be like josh and i
saying hey you know what
because we want to show that minimalism
isn't about
uh quantity it's about quality so we
bought rolexes
because we want to show we want to
appease a certain crowd
we want to appease the maximalists who
who feel like
you know minimalism is about the stuff
but see we got rolex's it's okay to have
rolexes
right and here's the thing i actually
think it's okay for you to have a rolex
and they're probably
good uses i mean initially it was a
diving instrument like it was the best
diving watch and that's why people had
it and it became a status symbol out of
that right
i assume the same the same is true with
a lot of sort of fashion
it starts in a way that is
useful but uh speaking about urban era
mcmanus
he said i think quite often we confused
minimalism when i was interviewing him
for this netflix thing
um uh quite often we we
confuse minimalism with utilitarianism
and i think the problem there is that
beauty is essential
yeah and and so i think aesthetics are
important we all believe aesthetics are
important and maybe sometimes what we're
trying to do with the
the sort of if you go to mosaic by the
way it's the most beautiful
building you'll ever walk in it's
gorgeous aggressively minimalist
um it's absolutely stunning um
and and none of that's a brand name it's
not like there's
a the the stage is brought to you by
nike or whatever right
but um there are sometimes we we
rely on brands i i don't i try not to
personally especially
outward facing brands we rely on brands
as a shortcut toward
quality or or something else
unfortunately i think that's the
unfortunate side but sometimes it's just
like
like ryan and i both drive toyotas we're
not sponsored by toyota but like
i know that the toyota has worked really
well for me and anytime i've deviated
from it i've i've regretted it in the
past
and so i've gone back to to to toyota
and that works
well for me although i was just in
nashville a few weeks ago
and the rental car places it was out of
most cars and they tried to give me like
a bmw and i'm like that's too fancy for
me like
i i because i'm afraid of the image i'm
going to
project i was also going to be hanging
out with dave ramsey then so i
really didn't want to like maybe i
should have sent you a card and you know
that
ford raptors i think is what he drives
yeah yeah but isn't that interesting
how that concern is valid yes
and it's interesting to to think where
that
stops like at a certain point like i
think even irwin said it
on a podcast uh very early on this blew
up and people were hitting him up like
i don't want to be owned by the mob or i
don't want
the opinions of others to dictate how i
dress or how i act which i think is a
valid thing
because that's living in a prison but
also there's something
wisdom related i think that you
understand what your image communicates
like instagram specifically the reason
that
if it's a gift or not doesn't really
matter is that all we have is the
context of what you choose to put out
there
and so a lot of the content that i put
out was
was just reposting pictures of what
these guys had already posted
and all i did was say this is how much
those shoes are worth and people lost
their minds and now people came back and
saying well they were a gift well they
were a gift like all right
that's good to know now but before you
it's it's kind of catch-22
but also i think what you just said
about the
declining the bmw is is what it's at the
heart of it it's like
that matters i think yeah again the same
thing
there is not there's nothing wrong with
bmw and by the way they're also really
aesthetically pleasing they're very well
engineered
um but at the same time to repair i'm
sure they are yeah um
uh so so but at the same time like it's
what it communicates i used to drive
lexuses
right now i don't now mainly
well two reasons one is they cost a lot
more than a toyota even though a toilet
is
functionally the same thing but the
other thing is what it signals right
and i before it was about status and i
need to
signal status and now for me i
i want to avoid the signaling altogether
but maybe
in a sort of meta way that's a different
type of it's meta signaling
right and so so the opposite could be
true you
we're going to later we'll have you look
at ryan's in my shoes and like maybe
ryan
what are those yeah seriously and
maybe what orion is signaling er er
what he's wearing and here's the weird
thing about all of this
i believe a lot of the people who are
wearing these these really high-end
things the the levi leskos and the um uh
uh judah smith
etc um and like you said many of them
are gifts i believe that
they could they're master communicators
absolutely
and they could get on stage barefoot and
it would send a different message
but i mean that's the reason that our
friend robel is so compelling
to me rob i watched that i watched those
or i listened to those conversations too
that's a really interesting guy
yeah he's he's he's the most fascinating
i mean and in fact he refused to even
put a sign
on their their church because he didn't
want any marketing to be involved
in bringing people in so it all had to
be sort of word of mouth and and
uh you know they had this old abandoned
mall that they met in in grand rapids
and
10 000 people showing up a weekend and
there was no signage and it was
aggressively minimal he didn't want the
the light shows and and the logos and
the brands and
people were always trying to get him to
sell merch and stuff and he was like i
can't imagine
selling something and so you could see
he was struggling with it and he he was
able to
to i don't talk about that publicly but
now
i see the other side of it i think it's
what ryan sees if you really believe
in a message and you think the best way
to communicate that message
to young people who you think need the
message the most and will benefit from
it from a protracted life
span then then
is the best yeah is it the best way to
identify with them to also look like
them in a way and maybe the shortcut to
look like them is to dress like them
yeah
maybe but then you're also that's
putting god in a pretty small box
like couldn't couldn't a
god so big that you believe in reach
that demographic without
trivial things like a nike swoosh like
that's the thing i go back on because
the argument seems valid like the logic
is there like
these guys or girls like this type of
clothing they live this kind of
lifestyle
oh they probably wouldn't relate well to
the guy in the suits and the stuffy pews
like i know how he like i realized how
we got here like i understand how we got
here
but also at the same end it's like dude
it's kind of a thin argument because
there's guys out here like
francis chan or tim keller who don't
wear anything flashy don't go on massive
like world tours with a bunch of strobe
lights and stuff sure and have huge
congregations although francis chan i
think
is i know who he is but i don't know who
the other guy is tim keller's is mass uh
new york city uh the church is called
redeemer he's very
big in christian circles i guess um so
he was famous for
reaching a bunch of young professional
new yorkers
by being this blazer khaki pants type
dude
that just came and was uh adamant about
what he believed and how he
is a really good speaker and everything
but no brands no flash
and so i i get the argument i think it's
probably a
thin argument respectfully like i think
if you believe in a god that created the
entire universe he can probably work
i don't even think you need to go that
far i think you could just say like even
like ryan's in my message i don't think
we need
we necessarily need to wear you know the
the coolest clothes or whatever
and in fact ryan came in here head to
toe and supreme i'd laugh at him
yeah right because it was probably fake
supreme yeah
no i i agree that that argument of while
i do it to draw in the younger crowd
like it seems a bit straw man to me it
seems a little thin
uh for me it comes down to like what
would jesus do
would jesus put on yeezys like i mean
when you look at what maybe i
i think i i've asked that question yeah
i think he might well when you yeah i
mean sure it's possible
but when you look at the way jesus lived
uh i mean he was you know he was a
minimalist and
uh he didn't go out of his way in fact
he would chastise
the pharisees and the priests that were
gaudy
and i mean he went after them personally
sure so what he
it's possible it's probably not
plausible that jesus would wear yeezys
let me give an argument why he might
sure so so first off
was he a minimalist yes definitely uh is
kanye west a minimalist
yes sure um and and so there are
different types of minimalists it
doesn't
doesn't mean good or bad you know steve
jobs was a minimalist but he was also a
total jerk so it doesn't mean just
because you're a minimalist you're
virtuous
as well right yeah and and so but i look
at
jesus and let's just say that
hypothetically
the the man who was jesus he performed
functionally magic tricks now
whether there was whether they were
miraculous or not
we could have that debate all day and no
one would win sure but um
was that at the time the best way to to
help people to draw people into the
message
and if so how different is that
from from doing something that is
that was the cool thing to do then is
the cool thing to do now but it's
different in the sense that he
was anti-materialism and the magic
tricks or the miracles did not promote
materialism
so but yeah right and so but you know
this also comes down to perspective
right
because you and i uh let's say we were
looking for a church
like i would not go and support the
pastor who was wearing the 800
yeezys but you might not have a problem
doing that and that's the freedom that
we have and i think that's what it comes
down to like we need to be able to make
our own decision about it like it's
and that's what i like about our podcast
is we get to you know explore different
perspectives and that's
what we're trying to do here is give
people different perspectives but anyone
listening to this really needs to decide
for themselves
what do they want to support yeah and
and one of the best ways to do that is
with our with our wallets and with our
other resources our time our attention
our energy our skills
those are our precious resources and we
often squander them on what's popular
now speaking of different perspectives
we have some questions here so let's
dive into some of these
brief from orlando has a question for us
over the past
several years i've endeavored to be very
intentional with any purchases that i
make
and i believe i've been successful the
problem that i'm having is that every
time i want to bring a new item into my
home
i find myself using a tremendous amount
of time
energy and often money to make sure that
the purchase aligns with my values
i spend a lot of time researching the
purchase trying to source it
from the used market and if i can't i
try to put a lot of money into making
sure i get a quality item that's going
to last a long time
as a result even though i'm buying less
and less over time
i find myself more preoccupied with my
possessions than ever
because i've invested so much into each
item
my question is how can i continue to be
intentional with my purchases
without feeling so attached to them so
at first
a few things come up tyler i think quite
often we we confuse
price with quality that's not always the
truth right
there's often a correlation yep but but
not not always
now here's the other problem is she's
always thinking about these things now
even after she's purchased them or
before she's purchased them
she's she's worrying about it and and
i i think that it becomes a bit of an
obsession and i think there are two
types of
obsessions there's healthy obsessions
that leads to good creativity and
uh and love and in many respects but
then there's these unhealthy
obsessions that don't serve the greater
good in a way and and i think maybe this
this this hypebeast culture that that we
we see now and it's been
especially expressed by what's going on
on instagram i mean that's really been
the way for us to
to see into everyone's life um it makes
us
obsess about what we have and especially
what we don't have
and in comparison to our peers or
people across the world that we've never
met uh the thing
this is something i struggle with all
the time i mean i am not a minimalist as
of now
would love to get to that point like if
we're being fully transferred we'll give
you a certificate before you leave oh
thank you so much
can i get the tattoo yeah um it's just
ten percent of your earnings
you get six dollars you're welcome uh
this is something i struggle with too
it's like especially now that i'm
becoming more aware like oh ethical
fashion is a thing like
like a an ethical supply chain is
something especially if i
claim to believe in a god that cares
about the poor widow and orphan
like this is something that i have to
think about more and it's it's given me
some anxiety like where does it stop
like where do i like do i have to look
at the silk
factory that this shirt came from or do
i have to look at the the
distribution center where the people are
working like the the conditions there
and so i
i resonate with her as far as um
maybe i don't know if she's feeling
anxiety but like the the stress about
thinking too far
into or or wanting to do the right thing
and not understanding or it owning you
like that whole process or that whole
thought process owning you
and something that's helped me um and i
do not do this well like
i struggle with my own materialism
issues but
giving and serving others to where it's
uncomfortable is something that helps
me release from that like having my
things own me
the the moment i'm giving to where it
hurts or where i'm
um helping someone where i i know i'm
not going to get anything in return
that at least gets me in a headspace
that says hey this isn't about you
and uh these things are just
worldly trivial things that really will
pass away
uh very quickly um and so that that's
been something i don't know if that
completely answers quite answers her
question but
the thing that's helped me have my
things not own me is to
give to where it hurts and then try to
serve others knowing that i'm not going
to get anything yeah in return yeah and
you realize many of the things that we
obsess about
they don't help us she talks about you
know
doing things that the the you know using
her time and energy and attention
and money appropriately but many of the
things that we
we acquire they don't serve the greater
good what i mean by that is they don't
they don't add value to our lives they
don't serve a purpose or
or help us contribute beyond ourselves
in a meaningful way
um they're really cool on instagram
though yeah yeah
you know it's interesting uh so julia
shore in our documentary talks about how
we're not materialistic enough in the
sense that we have this disposable
culture
brie is on this other side where she is
so focused
on obtaining the most materialistic
thing it's like she's on the other end
of
the spectrum uh yeah i totally agree
with what you're saying
like if she focuses more on giving
outwardly it might take away some of
that attention that she's focusing on
herself
but here's the thing too is like you'll
never buy the perfect thing and
i'm guilty of it too it's like we use
you know apple
computers i have an iphone um
you know you dig into what take out the
slave labor that you know apple uses but
look at what it does to the environment
i mean there are certain things there's
uh
i don't know yeah yeah exactly so
um you know it's impossible to buy the
perfect thing um
breed i would just say don't beat
yourself up too much like focus more on
giving focus more on helping others
and yes like that that is uh where
you're gonna help
give yourself like a good distraction i
guess i'd also i'd also
want to get to the root of that so like
if i'm if i'm her
it's probably not the things that are
really what she's trying to control like
if she's trying
as she mentioned having people come over
and trying to be super intentional about
what
uh she has in her house that's something
i'd want my community to help me examine
like to say why am i so obsessed with
wanting to do this perfectly
because maybe that's a deeper thing to
work on i mean that's something that
we've grown up in a world of materialism
and
even if you're trying to be a great
minimalist i assume there's maybe deeper
things that you have to work through
yeah it's a symptom of something much
deeper going on i totally agree i think
the one the one nice thing about
minimalism
when you feel like you're doing it
effectively it's often this
this lever that it's a set it and forget
it sort of thing
uh i remember when we interviewed the
minimalist architect for our documentary
frank
out in tucson and he had this house and
he he said he
took three years finding the couch that
he and so he was obsessing about that
couch right
in fact he couldn't find it so he had it
built custom just for his house and the
reason he did that though he said
i knew that i wouldn't have to make an
if i did it right this one time
i wouldn't have to make another decision
about the couch for the rest of my life
that decision is now made and i think
the same thing is true like ryan you
wear that outfit every day
and and that decision is now made in
fact it's one of the most difficult
decisions that people have to make every
day because they're making
that in the morning you get decision
fatigue do i wear this
this blouse with these shoes and and do
i you know whatever it is and all of a
sudden
you've used up seven or eight important
decisions in the morning
because you didn't have it set and
forget in the morning you just wake up
and you put that shirt on you put those
pants
on you do something with those shoes
and it looks great thanks man you know
what's interesting is
minimalism it helps me
it frees my mind to obsess about other
things
you know what i'm saying so it's the
healthy obsession thing right exactly so
i
so i don't if you're obsessing about
minimalism like you said tyler like that
is there's something deeper going on
um because minimalism for me is a it is
a set it and forget it type thing where
now i have the the mental capacity to
obsess about other things
yeah well brie i'm gonna send you a copy
of our minimalist rule book it's free so
anyone can download it the
minimalists.com
rule book because i think it's also
important to set up some boundaries or
what i would just call some limits
on on what's going on with with your
clothes so we have a couple rules in
there one in particular is
called the wait for it rule so if
something costs more than 30 dollars i
try to wait 30 hours
to buy it if it's more than 100 bucks i
try to wait 30 days
and it's because we feel so impulsive we
see it right there it's a click away i
mean literally it's one
click shopping it will and i live in los
angeles it'll arrive the same day
sometimes
instant gratification right and and so
i want you to delay gratification
because what you might realize is that
wow the thing i thought i needed the
thing that i obsessed over
has now become the object of distraction
for me or
worse the object of discontent so enjoy
the minimalist rule book
developmentalists.com
rulebook you can download it there for
free adam in long island has a question
for us
what i find challenging is i have
many items different clothing options
that
i could probably consolidate um if i got
rid of those
and got something else to take over that
place for instance i have
more in the northeast so it's cold and
our weather is drastic so i have a rain
jacket and a warmer jacket and then i
have a dress jacket for work
so but the problem is they're not
suitable to be switching back and forth
but if i got rid of those and purchased
something that was easier or more
versatile
it might make sense but then i fall into
that whole consumerism
and buying stuff and then buying more
stuff and getting rid of stuff so i'm
kind of stuck
i know the last episode you just talked
about you're getting rid of all your
socks and you're buying these new socks
and they kind of sparked that interest
and that knowledge and
um i was just wondering you know what
suggestions you have
should i just get rid of it and buy new
stuff or should i just use up the stuff
i have
so tyler what adam is he mentioned here
about the socks thing is once a year i
just
get rid of all my socks because they've
worn out and i buy 10 new pairs so
um it's it's different from what he's
sort of obsessing about which is
i've got this thing but it's not perfect
and i could buy the perfect thing and it
would be better for me
and and i think that's we really get
caught up in fashion and especially with
the
things that are trendy because the thing
that is trendy today is going to be
far from perfect tomorrow yeah right
and you're really highlighting a lot of
these things that are very
of the moment and in fact uh now that
the coronavirus is hit
your account has has slowed down because
the the material which you mined to
to start these conversations isn't out
there as much
right absolutely i mean it's pretty much
overnight gone away
yeah uh i mean and i i made a joke about
like
oh so nobody's going to church or even
really wearing shoes anymore
because everyone's sitting at home even
me like i've maybe worn one pair of
shoes over the past four months
because i haven't really needed to leave
my house or been forced to not leave my
house
um i do the i hear what he's saying like
i
at least empathize with kind of the
wanting to over research or
buy the perfect thing or like i always
search for the top rated whatever
top rated whatever yeah and at a certain
point
you just kind of gotta pull the trigger
but to the
if he's got jackets like if we're
talking about his exact question like if
he's
got jackets in the northeast and they're
functional i would challenge
the desire to want to buy the perfect
jacket yeah
because um like you said fast fashion
comes and goes i talked to with my
friend whitney bowk who
is a writer at fashionista she's the one
that gave me this fake name
um and she cares all about ethical
fashion
and we've been able to talk about how
uh terrible fast fashion is for the
environment
and for the people that work on it i
mean it's literally getting the cheapest
possible labor the cheapest possible
materials and creating it within the
time frame that the trend is popular and
then it goes away
and it's disposed who the hell knows how
um and so i would and i don't do this
perfectly either but i would challenge
the desire to buy the perfect thing if
you already have the functional
thing i'm the worst person to ask about
this my wife calls me a jacket [ __ ]
it's the one area it's the one area of
my life where i am i
i'm probably not a minimalist i think i
have nine jackets which is way too many
um and and especially since i live in
los
angeles um it's the nights are cool
though right
in the winters especially i'm like i've
got i've got a jacket for like every
eight degree increment
this is my 105 degree jacket but you
look so much better in outerwear though
it's like i'm obsessed with vests
because i get hot all the time but i
also like to keep my core warm and i
feel like
you never have to you never have to iron
anything if you wear a vest
you never have to iron a shirt you can i
mean it's mild
throughout like all seasons and i'm kind
of the same i'm probably a vest
[ __ ] if you're a jacket [ __ ] but big fan
of outerwear i mean i don't i
get i get how you i've gotten to that
title i
i love you know you talked about this
with breeze the delayed gratification so
i think that that's always a good thing
to
to uh uh to implement in your life if
you are
having these desires or these impulses
to buy new stuff but
it comes down to what is what are adam's
rules because like i
i'm trying to you know uh look at this
question and apply it to my own life and
what comes to mind for me is every time
i go to blue bottle
they have this beautiful scale they have
this beautiful
um teapot it's digital you can choose
the temperature
yeah the kettle so i i actually got my
kettle and my scale from blue bottle
like two or three years ago
but they've switched out they've
improved yeah and now they have these
beautiful sleek
modern and every time i see them i'm
like i'm gonna replace my kettle and my
scale
because these are so beautiful now is
there anything wrong with that
no like i i i know that josh you're
you are much more concerned about
aesthetics than i am
so you might look at it josh might look
at it and say you know what because this
fits in my home and because it's
beautiful
and if it's my style i am going to go
ahead and replace these things and
donate the scale
the old scale and the old kettle where
like me i'm more
functional so like none of my plates
match at home
my socks don't match speaking of socks
you know what i do i buy like
very bright socks but i i they never
match
because one will always wear out and if
i
if i had to replace socks every time
like then you know you gotta throw out
both
socks so if they don't match it's okay
if one sock wears out i still got half
of the set that i could wear with
something else
so it's advanced yeah so that is uh
that that those are my rules that's
that's my uh that's my approach
so adam the question is it's like how do
you how do you want to live your life
and like that's how you make these
decisions no matter what though i think
that delayed gratification
is uh something certainly people should
implement more totally agree
i think i differ from both of you a
little bit in that if i was personally
in adam's shoes i'd get rid of those
jackets and
and get a new one and here's why get rid
of three and buy the one perfect one
there's not gonna be a perfect one right
but i would find one that is going to be
more timeless and we're actually going
to on the maximum episode we'll talk
about
uh timeless style and how that's not
actually a thing but
and but i would i would find something
that's more appropriate it's going to
last you for
a longer period of time but also that
you feel good in because right now it
sounds like he doesn't feel good
anything he's wearing and
somehow it's hurting his confidence or
whatever that's a great point i'd find a
new home for those things where someone
else will actually get value from them
because you're no longer getting
value from those things i would find a
new home from so i wouldn't just throw
them away
and if they can have a new home someone
else might get value just because you're
not getting value from the thing
doesn't mean that someone else won't get
value from it in the future if you let
it go
and your willingness to let go in a way
then is a willingness to add value to
other people's lives by by letting it go
and then replacing it very intentionally
realizing whatever you bring in won't be
perfect
but you'll keep it for a longer period
of time you'll probably feel
better in the thing that you're wearing
as a result yeah
adam i'm going to send you a copy of our
book it's called essential it's an essay
collection with 150 essays 12 areas
of intentional living and one of the
essays in there
is specifically about clothes it's about
the favorite clothes of a minimalist and
i think you'll find
value in that so if you want the
audiobook version of essential
we'll send that to you it's over six
hours long or if you want the
ebook or the book book we're happy to
send those to you as well
ryan what time is it you know what time
it is it is time for our lightning round
where we answer your text messages
you can text your questions and comments
to 937-202-4654 yes indeed those texts
go to both of our phones and we
personally
reply to as many as we can we even
respond to some here on the podcast like
this next question uh by the way tyler
during the lightning round this will
ryan and i do our best to answer every
question with a short shareable less
than 140 character response
we put the tech yes very pithy yeah we
we put the text to these minimal maxims
in the show notes so they can copy and
share our pithy answers on social
media all right and uh you can find all
of our minimal maxims in one place now
minimal maxims.com i think there's a
drinking game like every time you hear
the word pithy on our podcast
yeah so i think i broke the seal take a
shot of nyquil that's right
that's right our question here is from
brian
how do we get in touch with our own
personal style
so that we don't fall for the tricks and
manipulation from advertising
now really we can just monitor on a bit
we'll give them something pithy here
but let's talk about this because there
are a lot of tricks i mean the reason we
start our show with advertisement suck
is because
we're just not a fan of of advertising
for us it doesn't work for us it's not a
judgment on someone else who who wants
to do advertising
um and and i've also realized there's a
lot of manipulation there and
it and i i find that it's easier for me
to be able to talk about hey i own a
toyota
because they're not paying me to say on
a toilet and in fact i'm paying them
but in a weird way that actually leads
to my pithy answer here is
are companies paying us to wear their
logo or did we pay them for the
privilege
of advertising on our bodies and
and and so i think quite often we're
trying to signal something we
we buy the you know the there's hundred
dollar multi-hundred dollar t-shirts or
some of the
the pants that you put on the preachers
and sneakers instagram
it's like 700 pens sweatpants yeah yeah
sweatpants wow um
i've owned cars that are less expensive
than right
and so and here's the thing they also
have logos so i paid 700
to sho to advertise for louis vuitton or
whoever to further someone else's dream
let's talk about his vision yeah i mean
it's hard for me to reconcile why you
would
ever pay 800 for sweatpants especially
for one with a logo
unless they were uh internet of things
completely
kitted out type sweatpants that helped
you do your taxes
or walk your dog or something yeah um
yeah i i studied marketing in undergrad
and so i i at least appreciate
the process of marketing and understand
like the utility of marketing like
companies
need people to sell and advertise for
their products if they want to succeed
as a company
i'm totally fine with marketing totally
fine with selling not great with
advertisements totally but i have a
very long 4 000 word essay on this we
won't dive into the details of it
but but um yeah and so in a way
we are we we are marketing for that
company
without without even knowing that we're
doing it
yeah i i really want to be in the
practice of
asking myself why i wear post buy
something um because
so much of that is at play and we don't
even understand it or don't even
uh understand how a brand name affects
our psyche so like
even the past couple years like
lululemon makes really
comfy clothes yeah and for for some
reason
the way they mark it makes me feel like
i need that pair of
pants or shirt for that tiny little i
mean i'm wearing the shorts now that
tiny little logo that makes me feel like
oh i'm i've got some level of status and
i've got these
really high quality pair of shorts that
not everybody could afford yeah
i want to know what that is and i want
to be constantly asking myself
if i'm falling into that i mean i think
that's what you're getting at is is at
least we should have intention with
why we choose to buy something or post
about something or
i think i think the lululemon is
actually a good example where they have
a logo but they go out of their way to
sort of tone it down it's not it's not
a very flashy it's it's not a giant pony
on my chest or whatever
um but it's still there and it's their
version of branding and
i own a lululemon jacket of course
and and uh what i can tell in fact they
offered to give it for free and i had
in fact they gave it to me for free so i
just donated the same amount
to the against malaria foundation for
the jacket
and the reason i do that is because i
don't want i want to be able to say hey
i have this
lemon jacket i i wouldn't feel good if i
just got it from them for free and then
started talking about it would feel like
an advertisement but um
i i i like the jacket i think it's fine
but i actually wish there was no logo on
it at all like
it's a very tiny very subtle logo but i
prefer
to be logo lists because i don't care
whether
you think it's an armani shirt or a
jcpenney shirt
it's what i feel comfortable in that's
what's important to me
i think it's crazy that we feel like we
can choose a brand to represent who we
are
as an individual right but then you end
up becoming like everyone else
and then the company sells for a billion
dollars yeah private equity holding
company
like i i also want to i think a lot of
people
that aren't minimalists struggle with
just even the tiniest bit of
identification with the logo so like i'm
even thinking about lulu tiny little
logo
but if i saw the same shirt or jacket
with like a russell logo
or something that said sam's club on it
yeah there's something in me that says
i don't that seems cheap or that seems
like i don't want people to see me
wearing that
i think a lot of people struggle with
that and i think that's uh
the inherent issue it's like that brand
means nothing as a human
yes that should mean nothing to us yet
for some reason a lot of us fall into
this trap of
i'd rather pay 80 for the lulu logo than
19
for the russell logo or the walmart
local logo or something that actually
kind of leads into my pithy answer which
is
what you wear isn't as important as what
you do
and you could wear those off-brand logos
and still be
a very likable a very popular person in
fact i think about wrangler
and how wrangler in high school like my
dad was so controllable over my outfits
because like we were we were i was
raised jehovah's witness
and uh they have this term worldly which
basically if you're not a jehovah's
witness
then you're worldly so any clothing that
i would wear that
looked a little bit outside of the you
know the religion uh he didn't want me
wearing worldly clothes
so we'd go to walmart and he'd buy me
wrangler jeans and i felt like crap in
them because i'm like oh these are
wrangler jeans
but now like i forget who it was i saw
like it was probably matt carney or
somebody like
pulling off wrangler jeans yeah yeah and
you know that you can get a walmart
and yeah it's just the kiss by my house
was selling wrangler jeans recently
yeah so called stranglers because
they're kind of tight you know
so so um one last thing before we wrap
up this minimal bit
um what do you think about our future
president kanye west
um he just did a deal with gap
apparently
and so like this is multiple layers of
of logos and signaling and
and and in culture and fashion and old
and new and supply chains and everything
else sort of
it's this gumbo of of of man
i see a lot of instagram posts about to
to
come up on your feed yeah i uh i posted
i reposted a tweet that i said um
recently and people freaked out about it
basically like kanye west would never do
a thing for publicity
and uh there's a lot of people in the
comment section that are defending like
who are you to question his faith who
are you to question
you know his intentions around running
for president and all i said was like
look i'm at least just raising an
eyebrow about why kanye west is running
for president
yeah um we're talking about it right now
yeah we're talking about right now and
kanye loves people talking about
him and what he's doing but also to his
credit connie's playing chess
i mean yeezy for the longest time with
nike didn't do that well like his his
nike air yeezys
are really popular and resell for a ton
but nike didn't really have a great
relationship with kanye
but then he went to adidas when adidas
at the time nobody really cared about i
mean
globally they were a huge brand but as
far as in the streetwear market
they kind of were irrelevant he goes
there and now it's a billion dollar
brand easy uh he does
he does sunday service and they're like
well this feels like a cult but then he
does this
massive tour with all this uh publicity
and now he's
publicly you know professed his faith
and now he's brought on this whole other
demographic of people that
before would have written him off you
know like during the college dropout
album years you know christians i'm sure
would have
never given him the time but now he's
appealing to both sides in a lot of ways
and so it's hard for me as like a
natural cynic to not be like
i don't this this feels like
there's he at least knows that he's
going to get publicity from this right
sure
and obviously i can't i can't know his
art i can't know his intent
but uh there's a lot of characteristics
of a duck
to not be like is this a duck i mean
because you know he's
he's got super gaudy intense tours he's
got
uh a wife that has her own level of
publicity and has a reality show that's
incredibly popular
there's no denying that he loves
the spotlight now again it's not a bad
thing the one thing i do have an issue
with is using
faith as a bargaining chip to try to
win over a certain voting block and i
think that's what a lot of people
are raising an eyebrow at is like did
you just do
all of these christian themed things in
order to
gain approval from a pretty significant
uh segment of voters and now you're
very quickly announcing that you're
running for president it just seems like
a lot of things are playing together
yeah it reminds me of uh trump in
2012 where he like started to make the
run
for president but it was very similar to
where it was people like blew him off
yeah so um very much from his handbook
trump's handbook yes i mean they're very
similar people yeah
large egos run businesses before not
afraid to be controversial i mean
kanye wearing the maga hat i mean people
freaked out about that but
yeah he him and kim are now billionaires
like yeah
he's playing chess right in front of us
maybe
i i don't know i mean uh it appears that
way i agree it doesn't look like i agree
it definitely appears that way or it
could just be a
series of dominoes that have all just
sort of tumbled in one direction
i'm not sure but the reason i bring it
up and and we'll end with this
um there are there are
a lot of people that i i don't know i'm
really just fascinated i brought this up
earlier i'm fascinated
with people who inspire other people and
there are people who do it well
there are people who don't do it well
there are people who do it well but with
the wrong intentions i
think of waco for example which by the
way if you saw i don't know if you saw
the the six-part series
tyler i mean he was born to play that
role unbelievable
um and and so i i even look at someone
like david koresh
and and see the sort of charisma and and
there are actually things you can tweeze
out say he did this right
and there's this whole belief backing
system that was
clearly wrong and a lot of things he did
wrong but you can tweeze out
even the good things from someone as um
wrong as as crazy as someone like david
koresh
and i i look at that but i i also look
toward a lot of
a lot of pastors today and even though
we might have different beliefs
i look at someone like erwin mcmanus or
judah smith or um
uh chad veach and and and look at the
way they communicate but not just them i
look at people like tony robbins
and and see how how they communicate
effectively uh oratorically especially
and
um i i try to to bring out the the
i don't know the best parts of it i i
wrote down this quote
this is from the the criticism section
of our wikipedia page this is from
um the the new yorker that's when you've
made it yeah that's right
the new yorker they said the minimalist
events are halfway between a ted talk
and a hipster mega church sermon
that's i actually find that as a
compliment and that and the same
attendees
right it's interesting because if i if i
thought you would do it
i would totally start having weekly
podcasts
in in la and it would be borderline
church service without the dogmatics
behind it
oh and there would be principles and
values and things like that right
like yeah yeah totally and so yeah i i
like the idea of doing your live
podcasts or
different things um i'm not a a fan
of of pre-prescribed you know
systems in in place and i think we're
actually seeing a lot of that right now
with
with the coronavirus and the quarantine
and you're seeing
even religion is is i say religion
specifically not spirituality but
religion the
way that people gather has now changed
everyone's sort of gathering online in a
way
and what the thing that inspired your
preachers and sneakers
instagram account that's how everyone is
is
consuming their sort of religious
services now right
yeah and it's it's i don't know
what the future holds with that but it
really forced
most churches to get on board with
the digital form of church because for
the longest time
uh i think judah smith specifically
there was a there was kind of an air of
rejection towards what he was doing like
building church home saying hey you can
have church
across the country and uh
in your living room and a lot of i think
traditional people that do traditional
church like dude there's nothing to
replace
in person community like you can't be so
isolated in your own home
and actively be involved with the church
but now since that's the only option
i think a lot of people are coming
around with or at least wrestling with
the ideas like what does this look like
now because
uh we don't know how long is it gonna
last and judah had the jump on a lot of
people and i think he
for sure uh he he had a really good
pithy quote that i'm gonna steal from
him but he said
uh in some interview he said i think the
church should
stop spending millions to reach
thousands and and instead spend
thousands to reach millions
and it's like dude that's a good
freaking quote right
although to i i think both things can be
true
you you can do this thing online like
ryan and i do most of what we do online
but there is no substitute for the
in-person events that we do yeah
we've done nine tours over the last 10
years we've got our 10th one coming up
later this year in in november and
and nothing yes it actually it's
it's not cost effective for us it
doesn't reach nearly as many people our
biggest tour we had 75 000 people show
on our biggest tour
um i can record one podcast and and
it goes out to many many many more
people than that right yeah
we spent an entire year on the road to
reach 75 000 people in person
it was literally 10 months 119 events in
100 cities eight countries
and and it's literally me and ryan
driving around in his toyota corolla
right yeah and and so i while i agree
with the the sentiment that i would
reach
more people the depth isn't necessarily
there yeah and and so there's there's
i think what we have to acknowledge is
probably room for both yeah
absolutely and i think uh i would
imagine as an introvert you were super
energetic after that world tour all
right i got a thousand for a month
dude did you really yeah it's like i'm
thinking cause i heard you say on
another conversation that you were very
much an extrovert yeah and
i agree like i need interaction with
real people in real life and this is why
quarantine has been so hard for me like
i've been in a depression
because i i love my wife and my wife is
everything to me but there is something
about being in groups of people that
uh it's hard to get at home with maybe
just one other person
and um yeah i totally don't think that
church home could be a complete
replacement
but i do think i think i agree with
judith sentiment that like dude we've
been building some gaudy ass
structures to reach 5 000 people
when we really could be investing in
spreading our message
at scale right and i think he's doing a
good job of that and you brought up a
lot of the communicators
i i agree they're outstanding
communicators and of course they're
going to build
huge platforms and have huge followings
um
i i just hope that they're
using that platform for good and i hope
that they're using those communication
skills and talents to further the
message
that uh god loves everyone well i i do
want to talk to you more about that
they're using it for good in particular
so when we get on
this maximal episode we'll talk about it
because we had one patreon supporter in
particular
he said you guys sometimes you recommend
the the war of art which is a book by
stephen pressfield
he's like but there's religious
undertones or he mentions religion
somewhere in the book and
and i just grew up in this religious
tradition that i felt battered
in and so there are some times where
people feel battered by
their their religion and so they're
instantly this whole conversation we've
had so far is probably
turning them off because even though
ryan and i again share radically
different beliefs
around this we share similar values and
what we'd like to do is explore these
different paths
and i think it's unfortunate if you're
not willing to even explore these paths
because
um maybe some past trauma so maybe we
can talk a little bit about that
yeah it's interesting because i actually
have that sentiment with war of art like
it's a great book up into that last
chapter
because that last chapter is like you
know it's just it gets a little
religiously woo-woo and uh
the rest of it is so practical
absolutely yeah but that so i i
have the same exact sentiment because i
am kind of traumatized from being raised
as
a jehovah's witness and uh yeah it's
interesting how i can hold space for
both though well let's talk about that
if we have a chance also uh we've got
some
listener tips and our added value
segment here in a moment but we have
some
surprise questions this week like should
pastors wear five
thousand dollar sneakers uh is marie
kondo stylish
i've kind of i've got some opinions on
her folding method that i want to talk
about i love how like recently we've
been doing a lot of marie condo
questions
we have questions coming in the maximal
segment uh what are some
what are some examples of timeless
outfits
we'll talk about timeless trendy maybe
uh how do brands affect people's free
will for choosing clothes
how do we see some clothes trends come
back into style or why do we see them
come back into style so the things that
were really popular
and the let's just hope the 2000s don't
come back in the style right
what the heck were the 2000s the jinkas
were nice yeah
true religion true religion yeah
we we got to talk about that the things
that were trendy
not that long ago are hideous now so
let's talk about the things that are
going to be hideous
in the not too distant future also do
you feel aspects of
the minimalist aesthetic creeping into
trendy clothing
how do you feel about that and can
simplicity be purchased
plus tyler is going to review my
footwear
and ryan's footwear it'll give us a
score of one to ten i think
tell us whether or not we're
instagram-worthy meaningful stuff
don't forget i slipped you that 10
billion
all right we got that a million more
questions for tyler jones if you want to
hear that check out our maximal episode
on the minimalist private podcast this
week it's a completely separate podcast
and it's just a couple bucks and it's
the most honest way for the minimalists
to earn an income because
we don't believe in advertisements so we
make money only if you find value in and
support
what we create head on over to the
minimalists.com
support to subscribe and get a personal
link so that our private podcast plays
in your favorite podcast app ryan what
else you got for us this week here are
some voicemail comments and tips from
our listeners check them out
hey there i am just listening to some of
your older podcasts and i came across
one where a caller was wondering about
letting go of baby clothes
one of the things that i've put in place
one of the rules that i've made for
myself
is that in order for me to hold on
to things from my daughter's childhood
which i'm a
person who is nostalgic i like to hold
on to things
i still have the flower dress that my
grandma made for me
when i was in my aunt's wedding and this
rule kind of goes along with that as
well but
i like to have a picture a good picture
of the item that kind of gives a
snapshot in time instead of just having
an item in a box
there needs to be a good picture to go
along with it to give it some context
to age the item and just to give it a
little bit
more meaning so for example i've held on
to just a couple
of my daughter's outfits from when she
was really little
and i have really good photos of her in
those outfits
and i just feel like it gives it a lot
more meaning than having a pile of
clothes that really have no relation to
her
to actually have a photo to go along
with the cute little outfit
it just kind of sparks those memories a
little bit more
the same thing with her artwork when she
was little i saved
all of her artwork and it piles up
after a while it's really fun when
they're really little but as they get
older you realize that you have tons and
tons of this artwork
and i started scanning things i would
date them and things so that i would
have an idea of when they came from but
once they pile up you really lose track
of
when they made those items how old they
were what school were they in
and they lose their their real
sentimental value
if they don't have a story to go along
with them
so her daycare used to send pictures of
them making their artwork
and so i've held on to just a few pieces
that i have really good photos of her
actually
making the item so that you know in the
future her
and i can pull those out and look at the
picture and be like oh you know do you
remember this
when you were making this and look at
the item at that time
and just keep a few things instead of
keeping everything and then i scan
everything else sooner or later i'll
put it together into a photo book or
maybe i won't but
at least i have a scan of it if i ever
want to take a look back or if she wants
to look back and try and remember some
of the things that she made
hi josh and ryan my name's alana from
rochester new york
i'm just calling in to share with the
world that i've
been becoming more sustainable and
trying to use
less physical items things that are
wrapped in plastic things that are
store-bought or brand new
i found this really great website called
marley's monsters
it's a small family-run business that's
in oregon and you can order
all sorts of awesome sustainable
goods from her website i just ordered
cloth paper towels that are reusable
washable sponges some hair scrunchies
some reusable straws so there's some
really great items if people want to
check that out and be more eco-friendly
all right y'all thanks again to tyler
jones for joining us today i guess i
think
best place to check you out is at
preachers and sneakers on instagram yeah
that's the best or twitter preachers and
sneakers with no vowels for some reason
that the name they won't let you have
that long of a name
we'll put a link to both in in the show
notes is there anywhere else we should
send folks
right now your podcast yeah i've got a
podcast uh cleverly named the preachers
and sneakers podcast
where we talk a lot about uh a lot about
some of the same things like consumerism
and capitalism
celebrity culture sustainable fashion
yeah i've talked with several
people there that uh talk really
eloquently about ethical fashion which i
think is something that a lot of
christians ignore
so there you know there's some christian
themes there but there's also some i
mean
we're all kind of questioning these
things and trying to discuss
more nuanced topics that's that's my
goal is to get people not only to laugh
but also
to think about things that maybe they've
known to be gospel
yeah beforehand so yeah the preachers
seekers podcast is probably my favorite
part about
running the account i love it and uh i
loved your conversation with kate
recently
oh she is the best woof yeah she
uh i'll see if we can get her on the
podcast uh i had jess reach out to her
oh cool yeah she's outstanding i mean
she she
is you know i even told her in the in
the conversation like she's a living
example of why the prosperity gospel
is false and i i want to disagree with
you about that so we're going to do that
on the max
okay okay okay good but i i love i love
the uh
i love the sentiment i think we might
agree violently yeah but um
but we'll get there via different paths
okay well yeah all that to say is she's
uh
one of my favorite guests that we've had
on she might be my favorite guest that
we've had on the podcast
we'll put a link to your your podcast in
the show notes as well thank you so much
for joining us today
thanks guys for having me this is fun
all right for our added value this week
ryan i figured i was just trying to
think about it what adds value to my
life almost every day
i still have pandora which you're such a
hypo doesn't give me any clout like yeah
it's
it's funny pandora's the new vinyl yes i
was gonna say dude like pandora went
from like being lame and only old people
used it
like everyone moved to spotify but now
it's like coming back around
well here's why i use pandora is they
they have
for me the best algorithm there's two
channels i listen to regularly
yeah and so every morning bex and i when
we have a coffee and we're reading
together we put on the cigaros
uh challenge check it out yes they're so
good and
for whatever reason the algorithm on
pandora works better than anywhere else
and it plays the
best soundtrack to my morning every
morning
dude he went and saw a cigarette in
concert in cincinnati
yeah didn't even know who they were it
was it was what is this
yeah it was a religious experience yeah
and then the next day he was like i saw
this amazing band cigarette
and i was in ohio i'm like why didn't
you tell me they were in town like i
would have went with you
it was yeah it was it was amazing um but
yeah you have to check out
their pandora channel every morning i
turn it on bex and i we just
and at night i listen to an aquilo chan
you know aquilo
oh you'll love them aquilo it's it's um
i don't know how to describe it it's
really chill
um atmospheric singer songwriter
it's it's gorgeous so yeah uh we'll put
a link to pandora
hopefully i think we can do the the
siguro station in the show notes as well
real quick for right here right now
here's one thing that's going on in the
life of the minimalists
my writing class is opening back up i
only do this two or three times a year
it's called how to write better it's a
four week writing class
um you can't get in it right now but you
will be able to soon it opens up july
31st and august 1st for 48 hours only
first 100 students
if you're interested in that i will give
you a bit of a warning so you don't feel
like i'm just trying to heavy sell you
on this
it is it requires uh a considerable
amount of time
seven to ten hours a week for those four
weeks if you're willing to put in the
work
i can show you how to write better over
a four week period i've had everyone
from high school students to people with
english as a second language take the
class all the way up to
medical doctors and grad students take
the class and i think a rising tide
lifts all boats and
people started writing into me after we
wrote our first couple books and saying
can you show me how to write better and
and i have a lot of questions about
writing
and as opposed to responding to every
thousand word email i
i just started this class many years ago
where i taught people in person we've
automated the class now we have a whole
community around it
and you can find details and you can
download the free ebook as well 11 ways
to write better
over at howtowritebetter.org if you sign
up for that email list over there we'll
let you know
when the class opens up you can follow
the minimalists on facebook twitter and
instagram at the minimalist come to one
of our live podcast shows
visit theminimalists.com tour to find a
city near you
if you have a question comment or
minimalism tip for our podcast email
voice memo to podcast at
theminimalists.com
you can comment on this episode at
youtube.com slash the minimalist
and if you want our show notes in your
inbox sign up for our email list over at
theminimalists.com we'll never send you
spam or junk or advertisements
but we will send you our simple sunday
emails whenever we send those out
we just sent one out recently with um
this new essay really short one but
uh it's called two mini screens and it's
a commentary on
uh did you see the the ronnie chang uh
stand up special
yes i've been talking with him recently
really yeah
he is one of my favorites right now he's
so good he has the so he has the joke on
there where he says
every night in america is like a
competition to see how many screens we
can get between our wall
and our faces yeah and we're not happy
with any of them right it's like
i've got my my ipad and my iphone
and then my laptop and the tv and then
the apple watch
and uh so it's an essay sort of about
that you can find that over at the
minimalist.com
screens sign up for the email list
you'll get that in your inbox i had this
epiphany about the screen thing where
because i do the same thing where i
reach for my phone when i'm watching a
movie
yes so uh what i've been doing recently
is i put my phone like in a change tray
that we have
uh where i put my keys and wallet and
stuff four year rule yes the four year
rule
or foyer rule if you're josh
so i'm sitting there and i'm watching i
think i was watching like star trek or
something
and what happens is there's this roller
coaster that happens with tv shows where
it's like boring boring boring and then
it builds up
and then you get this dopamine where
like it gets to this like plot point
and then it kind of comes down and like
that's the whole wave that i realize
that i'm writing when i watch a show
but what's happening with my phone is
that i want that dopamine hit
so so during the lull in the tv show i'm
like i can get that dopamine hit with
like social media
or with the news or with you know
checking my email
and uh it's it's just it just speaks to
our impulses the whole screen thing man
we're dopamine dopamine addicts in a way
yeah do you think that has anything to
do with the
the sneaker culture right now there's
some dopamine that's involved in that
right yeah
i think absolutely i mean buying things
in general probably gives you a dopamine
hit i do the exact same thing with the
movie my like my wife cusses me out
every time not
figuratively cusses me out for just uh
like dude i can do this both of these
things at the same time yeah
and you can't absolutely you know what i
end up doing i end up like
like because the plot point will hit and
i'll be like wait what happened what did
they say so then i put my phone down
rewind it
yeah oh dude yeah all right joe if you
leave me today with one message we hope
it's this
love people and use things because the
opposite never works
thanks for listening we'll see you next
time